[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight
the white house announced today it has
revoked the security clearance of former
ci director john brennan
it is considering doing the same to
other former government officials who
like brennan now work
as left-wing political pundits that
category would include former director
of national intelligence jim clapper
it's not clear why any of these men
still have legal access to classified
material the fact that they retained
that power after leaving government for
the private sector and punditry
is bizarre and it remained largely
unknown to the public until a month ago
when we broke the story
on this show brennan no longer works for
the federal government in any capacity
he holds
no official post and yet according to
two sources we spoke to exclusively
today
brennan retains perhaps the most
valuable asset he had in government
a top-secret security clearance brennan
is an out-of-the-closet extremist
this is not a man who should have a
security clearance
a month later that remains true john
bennett remains thoroughly discredited
and unbalanced just a few weeks ago he
accused the president of
treason for daring to hold a press
conference with a foreign leader
keep in mind that treason is a death
penalty offense responsible people do
not make that charge
for political reasons but brennan didn't
hesitate
he is i think the most divisive
president
we've ever had in the oval office he is
feeding and fueling hatred and animosity
and misunderstandings among americans
i use the term that this is nothing
short of treasonous because it is a
betrayal of the nation
he is giving aid and comfort to the
enemy
a betrayal of the nation would you want
a person who
say casually accuse people of murder
without evidence to get a security
clearance obviously you wouldn't
brennan is not different in a statement
released today brennan called the loss
of his clearance
an effort to suppress freedom of speech
and yet
brennan is the one who believes that
words alone speech
are a form of treason and should get you
sent to prison if not executed
that is unhinged the government is now
belatedly acknowledging that
lou dobbs hosts lou dobbs tonight of
course on fox business and he joins us
tonight
what would be the reason can you think
of a legitimate reason for john brennan
to have to retain a security clearance
after leaving government for punditry
i i can't even imagine why that would be
necessary
of why it would be frankly allowed after
his first personal
again personal attacks not policy
attacks personal attacks against the
president of the united states
and what we now suspect was a john
brennan inspired and led
assault on this president an effort to
subvert his campaign
and his administration through the good
offices
and helpful energies of the fbi
uh it is to me unthinkable that he would
be permitted
uh to be anywhere near one of our
intelligence agencies or any part of
this government
so you've covered the news for a long
time it wasn't that long ago
that the left was i think appropriately
wary
of bureaucrats who worked in secret of
our entire intelligence apparatus and
the idea of
unelected permanent washington undoing a
democratically elected politician
would have been horrifying to them and
now they're defending it or am i missing
something
no i think you are absolutely on point
and i think by the way
uh you deserve immense credit for
bringing this prominently to the
national consciousness
a month ago when you started taking up
the issue of why in the world
are these people who are attacking the
president united states personally
permitted security clearances how could
that even be permitted and i think you
deserve great credit for that
uh but in terms of the spectacle
of seeing the former fbi uh director the
former cia director the national
director of
intelligence james clapper absolutely uh
in in full-throated assault against
this president uh and attacking him as i
say
personally almost weekly and then it
became more frequent
we have never witnessed anything near
that in this country's history
i'm confused though if you if you ran
one of these agencies and you had an
institutional long-term interest in
preserving the credibility of that
agency
you'd be very upset with people like
john brennan or jim clapper because they
detract from your legitimacy
they give rise in people's minds to
questions about the deep state they make
people nervous
so why are they not telling these guys
slow it down get off twitter stop being
overtly political you're doing damage to
the institution which they are
there apparently is plenty of support
within the leadership
of those agencies the the holdovers the
leftovers if you will
from the obama administration not to do
precisely that
it is highly questionable to me why we
tolerated the former intelligence agency
heads
becoming part of the mainstream
political debate if you can call
their assault on a president personally
uh part of the mainstream debate
but they were attacking him vigorously
viciously unrelentingly
and it is a spectacle we have never as i
said
witnessed before and i can't imagine
that we'll ever permit
uh again it is the agencies themselves
have so much to
answer for if there was indeed the
russian uh
meddling in the election quote unquote
uh
why in the world didn't our agencies
those three agencies in particular know
about it and do something about it
to forestall it to prevent it or to at
least carry out retribution
for that under president obama this was
on his watch
not president trump's and president
obama
has much to answer for uh in leaving
behind
a a group of intelligence agency
directors
who carried on the ideological assault
publicly and without precedent in
american history
so lou finally clapper and brennan are
now
not government employees but employees
of television news networks right
you and i are also employees of
television news networks right have you
applied for a top secret security
clearance
should i apply for a top-secret security
clearance
i i personally i i think i've said this
to you before i'm going to hold out for
subpoena power
i will leave it to you and others
to preserve the security clearances
okay i hope you get it by the way thank
you very much
thanks appreciate it tucker